ब्लुटूथ नमस्कार चमक सीखिए हिंदी में कि
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
सीखने वाले हैं जर्मन केस पार्ट-2 इसमें
आज हम सीखेंगे आए हैं वह बोल और सीखेंगे
और उसका उपयोग करके मेरा तुम्हारा उसका
इसका वगैरह सब करना सीखेंगे और उसके लिए
बहुत जरूरी है कि आपने इसके पहले वाला जो
वीडियो था जर्मन के से शिव वह ठीक से देखा
हो कि अगर आपने वह ठीक से देखा है और जो
भारत सेंटेंस वहां पर मैंने बोले थे वह
अगर आपने ठीक से समझे हैं और कुछ से लिखे
हैं तो आवाज आपको यह बहुत ही इजी है आपको
बहुत ज्यादा कुछ नहीं याद रखना होगा और
बहुत ज्यादा सीखने वाले जो आज तो मेरे
आपसे फिर से एक बार रिक्वेस्ट है अगर आपके
दर्द कंसेप्ट क्लास वीडियो के क्लियर नहीं
है तो फिर एक बार वह वीडियो देखिए और फिर
यहां आइए नेक्स्ट 10 से 15 मिनट में आपको
तो मॉल और मेरा तुम्हारा सब कुछ भी क्लियर
होगा
यहां पर शुरू करते हैं सबसे पहले कदम
क्विक रिवीजन लेते हैं आपको स्क्रीन पर
अपना दर्द पास वाला टेबल दिख रहा होगा वन
सक्रिय न एक्टिव पर है मेल-फीमेल न्यूट्रल
प्लुरल दूसरे एक्सेस पर है नॉमिनेटिव
पॉजिटिव करता है कर्म है या विद के साथ को
याद है एक पुत्री सेंटेंस करके देखते हैं
आए हैं वह आई है वह बोल दो बोल हमने
डॉक्टर लांच किया था सबको याद होगा बॉल
क्या है कर्म है ऑब्जेक्ट अकुलाकर मैं
आपको ट्यूबवेल के को टेबल में इस खबर दिन
बाल बहुत ही इजी है राइड क्लियर है अगर वो
टेबल सिंपल है तो जैसे तथा एवं ड्रॉप ऑइल
तो आइए मैं स्पेसिफिक बॉल के बारे में बात
कर रहा था जब मैं बोलता हूं यह बॉल तो कोई
भी एक बॉल दूं तो कोई भी एक बॉल दो चलेगा
इसे मैं बोल रहा हूं तो आप क्या कर रहे हो
और इन डिफिकल्ट इंग्लिश में दर्द डिफिकल्ट
है और कभी भी एमपी होता है
तुम्हारे यहां यह डिफिकल्ट है मतलब इस नोट
डिफाइनिंग जर्मन में और बेसिक जो आप बोलते
हो कि अब बच्चों की एक बूंद और करेक्टर तो
जर्मन में उसका होता है आइए आइए पर जैसे
देर दांत चला था वैसे वहीं भी चढ़ता है तो
वह कैसे चलता है वह हम देखेंगे तो अब
स्क्रीन पर आपको यह टेबल दिख रहा होगा
एक्सेप्ट इससे ट्रिपल एक्स सेम है वह मैच
से में है बजे क्या है वैल्यूज बदले हैं
को प्रकट या उससे माय हम दो बोल बोल रहे
थे अभी माय व बिल्कुल तो अगर और है तो हम
यह टेबल यह मंत्र याद रखेंगे बोलो मेरे
साथ आई एम आई लाइनर आई न न न न न न न न
मैं तेरे सबको दिख रहा है
मैं अभी आपको आपमें से कुछ लोगों को देखा
होगा कि वहां पर ऐड एंव एंड में क्यों
लिखा हुआ है तो उसका रिविज़न जो है वह में
एपिसोड के एंड में बताऊंगा पर वह चिकारा
एंड एब्रॉड तो होता नहीं क्योंकि और सिंह
भुल्लर बेसिकली और कार स्पीड फ्लोरल तो
वहां पर मैंने लास्ट पॉइंट पर क्यों लिखा
है हम मंत्र भी आईना आईना आईना आईना क्यों
बोल रहे हैं वह हम एपिसोड के एंड में डेढ
ठीक है उसको अभी छोड़ दो अब हमारे नार्मल
सेंटेंस बनाते हैं ठीक है चलिए बनाते हैं
को शुरू करते हैं नॉमिनेटिव से ड्यूटीज आफ
ऑल ऑफिस आफ और एक मॉल है तो बॉईल इसमें
क्या है करता है दिस इज बाल तो आप अभी
अंतरिक्ष को छोड़कर तब हो तो को करता है
सब्जेक्ट नॉमिनेटिव मेल क्या है दो टेबल
में आई एम और दूसरी चीज दिस इज दिस
पिंजरों में दास होता है हिंदी में भी
होता है एक मार्किंग एक से ज्यादा मीनिंग
होते हैं वैसे यहां पर यह दाग का उद्देश्य
से कुछ लेना-देना नहीं है तो क्या होगा
दास इस्ट आइन बाद क्योंकि नॉमिनेटिव में
वैसे ही दिस इज अ वॉच अंडर लेंस करो कि
आपको सब्जेक्ट नॉमिनेटिव फ्री में क्या है
देखो आई न दास इस्ट आइन उल अव्वल थर्ड दिस
इज अधिकार और नीचे लाइन सब्जेक्ट
नॉमिनेटिव नॉट र हार्टिस्ट सेल्यूट टो हिम
में का पहला पेपर या है तो कुछ नहीं है
आपको सिटी में जाते हैं आय हैव तो बोल अब
बोल बोल क्या है अब जेड तक पॉजिटिव मेल आई
ने इस हावड़ा इन थे मिडस्ट को बहुत ही
सब्सक्राइब फॉलो करता है वह वॉच माय चैनल
लाइक करो ऑब्जेक्ट फीमेल इन व्वे के लिए
आए हैं ओके अब jain5 टो थे वेरी सिंपल टो
प्ले विद थे व्होल स्कूल मिटाई बॉल
कि आई प्ले विद अवार्ड पांच पिछले वित्त
वर्ष अगेन विदाउट यू है प्लज वॉच है कि
मेघनाद की डिजाइनर इश्क लव मिठाई न लेते
हैं आइए प्ले विद थोक दाम न्यूट्रल इस
पिलर मिठाई नेम टो कुछ भी नहीं है सिर्फ
टेंपर्ड ग्लास बदले कुछ भी नहीं है
मैं अभी हम इससे भी इजी और सिंपल कंसेप्ट
देखेंगे पर उससे पहले थोड़ा फिर से हिंदी
को तें अब हिंदी में देखें मेरा भाई मेरी
मां हां यह मेरे दोस्त यह मेरा मेरी मेरे
अपने क्योंकि हम मैं तो एक ही हंसी क्यों
क्योंकि मेरा भाई मेल है मेरी मां फीमेल्स
इसलिए तो डिपेंडिंग अपऑन जेंडर आपने मेरा
मेरी बदला इंग्लिश में ऐसा नहीं है
इंग्लिश में माय ब्रदर माय मदर राइट पर
जर्मन फिर भी अपने जैसी है तो जर्मन में
तो यह आपके जैसे माइंड भी वक्त है मतलब
लाइन है जर्मन में तो उसका भी - - - - इन
ऐसे फोल्ड टेबल बन जाता है इससे कितने
टेबल करोगे मेरा के लिए करोगे तेरा के लिए
करोगे उसका इसका हमारा उनका जनरल लोग अपने
तारे टेबल करने जाते हैं और फिर कैसे थार
डेजर्ट बोलने
यहां पर मैं आपको एक बहुत आसान ट्रिक
बताता हूं वह ट्रिक अगर आपको समझ में आएगा
तो आपको एक भी टेबल याद नहीं रखना पड़ेगा
सिर्फ छह नए वर्ड्स सीख हैं और मेरा उसका
इसका उसकी 13 सब कुछ आ जाएगा लेकिन यह
ट्रिक देखो अगर इस मतलब मैं है जो माय माय
वह जर्मन उसके लिए मुझे रिमाइंड याद रखना
है उसका कैसे चलेगा वह बाद में देखेंगे
माय के लिए माई नहीं आते इस्माइल
है तू के लिए याद रखना है टाइम युवक
को शेयर और इस दोनों के लिए उचित और इट्स
के लिए जहां 30 रावण माइंथ सहित जी के लिए
शिवहर अगर है तो है क्लियर क्लियर और हुई
एक हम है हमारा के लिए है उन अगर कुंजर
दोनों है कि यह जो है उसका त्यौथर यज्ञ
हेयर ऑइल
कि एक बार देखा फिर आप उसका नाम भी नहीं
लेंगे फिर नोट यह यूज्ड इन जर्मन ओके और
फिर दे देवें योग है जी तो उसका फिर से
होगा देर के लिए शेयर और आप वाला कैपिटल
जी है उसका होगा क्या विटठल क्लियर आपका
फिर से देखते हैं माय माय यू आर द प्राइम
चीज ऐड त्यौहर इस हेयर अवर इस कुंजर तुम
दोनों का बेसिक जो करेक्टर में तुम दोनों
का इस त्यौहार और
कि उनका देअर इज अगले नियर और आपका इस
कैपिटल सीरवी यह तेरे को यह तीन बार है
अगर आप देखोगे 6 वर्ड है आपको अपने सीख
लिए बस अब इसका यूज करके उस ट्यूबल सारे
कैसे ठीक है मैं आपको बताता हूं एकदम
सिंपल आए देखो मेरे साथ आए प्ले विद माय
कार आईएस प्लेज्ड विद माइकल तो क्या करना
है और अगले दिन जैसे मैं पहले बता टेक्स्ट
जॉब नहीं करना है जो जंप करेगा उसकी गलती
होगी स्टेप बाय स्टेप करना है आई प्ले विद
माय कार माइक को रिप्लेस करो और से इससे
उसे और अभी आई प्ले विद और का अवकाश के
लिए क्या होगा रिकॉर्ड ट्यून आइटम क्या
होगा नेम तो इसीलिए हम करेंगे आई नेम और
फिर मायका और किया था इसलिए फिर लाइन का
रिमाइंड करो वापिस दे दूं कि यह किस जगह
हुआ यह लोग तो क्या होगा इस पिरामिड माय
नेम आफ्टर
हुआ है अगर आपने भी तीव्र कारण होता तो
युवकों व से रिप्लेस करते हैं बाद भी
वापिस देते हैं फिर मैं आई एम की जगह धुंध
स्पीड लिमिट दाहिने मऊ टो ऐसे योगा स्पीड
लिमिट सिनेमा टो उस प्लम्मेट अंदर अमाउंट
ऑफ कुछ नहीं करना है मां यूअर हिस घर जो
भी है उसको रिक्वेस्ट करना है तो उससे तो
करूं बना और फिर से उसको महेंद्र सिंह
ढींढसा रिलीज़ करो हम पांच एग्जांपल्स
लेते हैं तो आपको यह कंसेप्ट आपके दिमाग
में पूरी बैठ जाइए ठीक है
है तो पहले करते हैं आए हैं बोल एकदम
सिंपल से शुरू करते हैं बोल क्या है हमारी
स्टेप माइक वांडरिंग करो ऑयल को और का
क्या होगा बॉल क्या है आपको रियर ऑब्जेक्ट
तक पॉजिटिव मेल आईने आई को रिप्लेस करो
मैं से इस खबर - बाल अगर आपको मेरा वॉल्व
पूछेगा नेक्स्ट
लव यू लव यू आर यू हैव योर वॉच फिर से योर
रिप्लाई किससे कहोगे उपर से अ वॉच अब जैक
एक्विजिटिव फीमेल आईएस न इसीलिए का यह
दोहा अड्डा इन आवर दोहा टेस्ट डाइनर
को ही रिप्लेस विद ही झाल ही प्लेस विद
हिस कार इसको वंडरलैंड करो और से रिप्लेस
करो विद कार डाट यूनाइटेड माइ नेम माइ नेम
का होगा कहीं को रिप्लेस कर जान शेड्स
पेस्ट मिट जाए नेम टो नेक्स्ट जो है वह
इंपोर्टेंट है यह आपको समझ में आए तो आपको
किससे समझ में है
है जिसे देखो चीन लफ्ज़ हर फादर शे लव्स
हेर फादर सूचना हर कोई क्लिक करना है और
से फेस्टिव जाओ तो कंजूस नहीं होंगे और
गौर से रिप्लेस करो फादर क्या है और जेड
तक पॉजिटिव मेल आईडी इन थे नाइंथ आई एम को
डिक्रीज़ करो यह से क्लियर रन फास्टर क्या
होगा इजीलि ट्वेंटी ईयर्स आफ्टर एकदम
सिंपल लास्ट टाइम सेंटेंस लेते हैं विद
लवर मदर बिलव्ड मदर को प्ले करो तो क्या
होगा अब गुस्सा क्यों फीमेल फीमेल वीरवार
को एकदम सिंपल है बट कुछ नहीं करना है सेट
समझ में आई जो भी तुम्हारा माय यूअर ही
इज़हर जो भी करना है तुमको मेरा तुम्हारा
उसको अ से रिप्लेस करो और का रूप बनाओ और
उलटा अगर यह व को रिप्लेस किया तो टाइम्स
रिप्लेस करो इसको रिसेंट करो एग्जाम सिंपल
है बट अभी अभी आपको याद होगा मैंने आपको
बोला था कि ऊपर हो एम क्यों लिखा और वहीं
का रूप हमने पूरा में क्यों देखा उसका
आंसर मैं अभी आपको देता हूं ठीक से समझ लो
अभिनेत्रियां सेंटेंस देखो आई प्ले विद
माय कार या Aeroplane विथ माय कार तो अपने
रूम के हिसाब से हम क्या करते हैं माइक
वंडरलैंड करते और उसे रिप्लेस करते हैं पर
अगर हमने वह आईना का रूप ही नहीं सीखा
होता तो रिप्लाई स्पीकर समझ कर इसीलिए
आपको माइंथ बाद में आसानी हो इसलिए हम
वहीं वासी ब्रायन दोहराई ने तब क्या करोगे
डेटिव
है और डाकियों है करेक्ट और प्लूरल डाट यह
प्रॉब्लम क्या है देखो आइए इन थे इसीलिए
होगा इस पिलर मिनट माइनर कम टो टर्म्स विद
योर कार स्पीड लिमिट त्यौथर सिंपल सबको
समझ में आया कि हमने पहले वह क्यों किया
अगर आप उसको अगर आपको फिर भी माइंथ के भरे
कट्टे व याद रख अपने साथ और टेबल टॉप याद
रख सकते हो और वह हार्ड है इससे यह बहुत
सिंपल है एक डायन का टेबल याद रखो और उसको
रिप्लेस करते जाओ ठीक है तो अभी आप क्या
करोगे लास्ट में मैंने ट्राय सेंटेंस देखे
थे आज हमने नॉन सेंटेंस देखे हैं मैंने
आपको मदर फादर भी दिया है वोटर पाटम ऊपर
मतलब अगर टमाटर मतलब फादर भी दिया है और
आपको बॉल बॉल ओवरऑल तो आता है इन्हें
थोड़े से कंडंस इधर-उधर के बनाते रहो तो
आपको थोड़ा सा कॉन्फिडेंस आ जाएगा यह सब
को तो आज हमने
श्रवण को तरुण मेहरा कुछ ज्यादा नहीं है
लाभ करना है टेबल तो लव करना हमने लास्ट
टाइम किसी का था आज हमने सिर्फ याचिका
कैसे दायर अकाट्य बनता द के लिए धन की
व्यवस्था खत्म विशेष तौर के लिए आईना आईना
कटी हुई है और उसका यूज करके मेरा
तुम्हारा इसका उसका हमारा वह कैसे बनाना
है वह आज हमने सीखा मुझे आशा है कि आप सब
तो यह कनेक्ट समझ में आई होगी नेक्स्ट
क्लास में हम प्रकाशित जर्मन प्रपोजिशन हर
प्रपोजिशन ऑक्सिडेटिव हो सकता है यह जो भी
हो सकता है बाहर में दिखने वाले हम यह जो
प्रपोजिशंस हैं हमने एक्स्ट्रा इसमें
इंपोर्टेंट यह लेवल इंपोर्टेंट प्रपोजिशन
सीखने वाले हैं वह वीडियो में दो-तीन
दिनों में डालूंगा तो अगर जैसे मैंने बोला
कि आप मेरे चैनल को सब्सक्राइब कीजिए और
बेल आइकॉन दबाएं है तुझे गोल्ड वीडियो अब
होगा आपको अपने आप पता चल जाएगा तो और यह
उस वह वीडियो आने से पहले अगर वह
ऐसा करने से पहले अगर आपने यह दोनों
संस्कृतियों से किए होंगे जो 220 2825
सेंटेंसेस हमने दिए वह अगर आपने किसी कर
लिए होंगे तो वह खुली जब नेक्स्ट क्लास
खत्म होगा आपको किस साले आपको क्लीयर
होंगे ठीक है मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में
धन्यवाद